>> IT'S TRAGIC WHAT'S HAPPENED.
I THINK IT'S UNNECESSARY.
I THINK WE MADE A SERIOUS
MISTAKE IN DOING IT THIS WAY.
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT THE
AFGHAN PEOPLE.
IT'S ABOUT US AND OUR SECURITY.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE NOW GOT THIS
GROUP BACK IN CHARGE OF
AFGHANISTAN.
THEY WILL GIVE PROTECTION AND
WILL TO AL-QAEDA.
YOU GOT ISIS ALREADY IN THE
COUNTRY TRYING TO OPERATE AT THE
SAME TIME.
YOU KNOW, YOU LOOK AROUND THE
WORLD AND THE ONLY PEOPLE REALLY
CHEERING THIS DECISION ARE THE
PEOPLE HOSTILE TO WESTERN
INTERESTS.
BRET: FORMER BRITISH PRIME
MINISTER TONY BLAIR TALKING
ABOUT THE SITUATION CURRENTLY IN
AFGHANISTAN.
OVER THE WEEKEND YOU MAY HAVE
SEEN ON "FOX NEWS SUNDAY"
CURRENT SECRETARY OF STATE TONY
BLINKEN TALKING TO CHRIS
WALLACE, ASKED ABOUT THE
CONTRADICTORY STATEMENTS OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN, AND HIS VARIOUS
PRESS CONFERENCES.
>> DOES THE PRESIDENT NOT KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY
EMOTIONAL TIME FOR MANY OF US.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID AL-QAEDA
IS GONE.
IT'S NOT GONE.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE HAS NOT
HEARD ANY CRITICISM FROM THE
ALLIES.
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
CRITICISM FROM THE ALLIES.
WORDS MATTER.
AND THE WORDS OF THE PRESIDENT
MATTER MOST.
>> CHRIS, ALL I CAN TELL YOU IS
WHAT I HAVE HEARD AND, AGAIN,
THIS IS A POWERFULLY EMOTIONAL
TIME FOR ALLIES AND PARTNERS AS
IT IS FOR ME, AS IT IS FOR US.
BRET: LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL
GUY BENSON HOST OF THE GUY
BENSON SHOW ON FOX NEWS RADIO.
HAROLD FORD JR. FORMER TENNESSEE
CONGRESSMAN AND TREY GOWDY
FORMER CONGRESSMAN FROM SOUTH
CAROLINA.
TREY, I WAS STRUCK BY THAT
ANSWER BY THE SECRETARY OF STATE
THAT IT WAS AN EMOTIONAL TIME
FOR ALL OF US.
ANSWERED SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT'S STATEMENTS BACK AND
FOR THE.
IT'S REAL EMOTIONAL TIME FOR THE
AMERICANS ON THE OUTLINES OF
THAT TALIBAN RING.
>> TONY BLINKEN SAYS EMOTIONAL
BEING ON CHRIS WALLACE'S SHOW
TRY HANGING ON TO THE WHEEL OF
AN AIRPLANE THAT'S TAKEN OFF.
BUT, YOU KNOW WHAT, BRET?
THE ONLY THING THAT'S BEEN WORSE
THAN THE POLICY, THE EXECUTION
OF THE POLICY HAS BEEN THE
EXPLANATION FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION THEY CAN'T AGREE
WITH AL-QAEDA IS STILL THERE OR
NOT OR THE AIRPORT IS SAFE OR
WHETHER BIDEN WAS GIVEN
DIFFERENT MILITARY ADVICE.
THEY ARE FECKLESS AND THE BEST
DEBATES IN WASHINGTON RIGHT NOW
ARE THE ONES TAKING PLACE WITHIN
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
BRET: IT IS QUITE SOMETHING TO
SEE, HAROLD THEY CHANGE WITH
PETER DOOCY TODAY ABOUT STRANDED
AMERICANS ALSO RAISED SOME
EYEBROWS.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> MOST OF THE CRITICISM IS NOT
OF LEAVING AFGHANISTAN.
IT'S WAY THAT HE HAS ORDERED IT
TO HAPPEN.
BY PULLING THE TROOPS BEFORE
GETTING THESE AMERICANS WHO ARE
NOW STRANDED.
DOES HE HAVE A SENSE OF THAT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I THINK IT'S
IRRESPONSIBLE TO SAY AMERICANS
ARE STRANDED.
THEY ARE NOT.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO BRINGING
AMERICANS WHO WANT TO COME HOME,
HOME.
BRET: ALL RIGHT.
HAROLD.
CLEARLY WILL THERE ARE AMERICANS
WHO FEEL STRANDED AND THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO GET TO THE
AIRPORT.
WE JUST TO TO STIPULATE THAT
THERE ARE 8 DAYS UNTIL THIS
DEADLINE THAT THE PRESIDENT
APPARENTLY IS DECIDING ON ON
AUGUST 31st.
SO, WHAT ABOUT THAT?
>> FIRST, IT'S GOOD TO BE WITH
YOU.
I THINK THE 8 DAYS FROM NOW,
THAT'S WHAT WORRIES AND CONCERNS
ME THE MOST.
AND WE CAN PARS WORDS, AND I
KNOW AND LIKE JEN PSAKI.
I DO THINK THERE ARE AMERICANS
THAT ARE STRANDED THERE, AT
LEAST THEY FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
STRANDED.
THE CONTEXT.
I AGREE AS I OFTEN DO, I AGREE
WITH TREY THAT THE -- WE ALL
WANTED TO EXIT OR MANY WANTED TO
EXIT BUT THE EXECUTION IS THE
PROBLEM.
SERIOUS MINDED PEOPLE HAVE TO BE
WILLING TO SET ASIDE THE
POLITICS HERE FOR A MOMENT AND
LET'S FOCUS ON DEMOCRAT AND
REPUBLICAN WHAT RESOURCES WILL
BE NEEDED, IF THE TALIBAN IS TO
BE BELIEVED THAT THEY WANT US
OUT BEFORE THE 31st AND AREN'T
FOR EXTENDING THE DEADLINE, WHAT
ARE WE PREPARED TO DO?
I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS GOT TO
THINK LONG AND HARD ABOUT THAT
AND BE READY TO ARTICULATE THAT
TO THE COUNTRY.
I LISTENED TO PRIME MINISTER
BLAIR THE FORMER PRIME MINISTER.
I LIKE HIM, TOO.
HE ALSO WAS PART OF AN EFFORT
THAT DIVERTED RESOURCES UNDER
PRESIDENT BUSH HE AGREED TO FROM
AFGHANISTAN COUNTER-TERRORISM
EFFORTS TO GO WAR WITH IRAQ
CHIRKS THINK HISTORY WILL PROVE
PROBABLY WAS A MISTAKE.
I VOTED FOR THAT WAR BASED ON
WHAT WAS TOLD TO ME IN THE
CONGRESS.
THERE IS NO DOUBT OCCUPYING
FORCES IN PAKISTAN DON'T WORTH.
ALEXANDER THE GREAT FORCES
THERE.
I T. EXCUSE WHY THIS PRESIDENT
AND I WOULD ARGUE PREDECESSOR
COULDN'T GET A BETTER DEAL TO
GET THE EXTRACTION OF AMERICANS
OUT BUT AFGHAN ALLIES.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR PRESIDENT
BIDEN IT'S ON HIS WATCH NOW.
AND AS HE SHARED THE OTHER DAY,
THE BUCK STOPS WITH HIM AND
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE A
BETTER PLAN IF IT EXTENDS BEYOND
AUGUST 3 st TO GET AMERICANS
OUT OF AFGHANISTAN SAFELY.
BRET: THE THOUGHT NOW, GUY, THAT
THIS DECISION HAS TO BE MADE
PRETTY QUICKLY IF IT IS GOING TO
BE A DEADLINE OF AUGUST 31ST AND
THE NEXT 24 HOURS, THEY NEED TO
COME UP WITH, YES, THAT IS OR
NO, THAT ISN'T.
THE TALIBAN SAYS THAT'S A RED
LINE FOR THEM WHY WE, AS THE
GREATEST MILITARY IN THE WORLD
CARE ABOUT THAT, I DON'T KNOW.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> NOT ONLY CARE ABOUT IT, IT
SEEMS LIKE IN SOME WAYS WE ARE
PARALYZED OR BEHOLDEN TO IT,
WHICH IS SORT OF A SHOCKING TURN
OF EVENTS.
YOU ARE RIGHT, THAT DECISION HAS
TO BE MADE VERY SOON.
PART OF THE PROBLEM HERE, BRET,
IT SEEMS LIKE MANY DECISIONS
INVOLVING THIS WITHDRAWAL SHOULD
HAVE BEEN MADE WEEKS OR MONTHS
SOONER THAN THEY ACTUALLY WERE.
AND GOING BACK TO THAT CLIP OF
JEN PSAKI TODAY IN THAT EXCHANGE
WITH PETER DOOCY, I HAVE BEEN
MYSTIFIED REPEATEDLY ON THE
POLICY AND THE MESSAGING CHOICES
OF THIS ADMINISTRATION ON THIS
ISSUE AND THE WITHDRAWAL IN
PARTICULAR.
I WAS PARTICULARLY MYSTIFIED BY
HER CHOICE, THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY'S DECISION THAT
SHE MADE TO PICK A FIGHT ON
PARSING THE WORD STRANDED
INVOLVING THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS
AND ALLIES WHO DEFINITIONALLY
STRANDED RIGHT NOW.
THEY DIDN'T SAY ABANDONED.
PETER DIDN'T SAY ABANDONED.
THERE IS EXAMPLE AFTER EXAMPLE
POURING IN FROM PEOPLE AMERICANS
AND OTHERWISE WHO FEEL AND ARE
STRANDED AND THIS IS ONCE AGAIN
IT GOING -- IT GOES BACK TO THE
POINT THAT CHRIS WALLACE WAS
HAMMERING ON THAT THE CANYON
BETWEEN THE RHETORIC OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE REALITY
ON THE GROUND AND THEY STEPPED
IN IT AGAIN TODAY.
BRET: YEAH.
QUICKLY, I MEAN, POLITICS IS A
PART OF THIS.
IT'S ALWAYS A PART OF ANYTHING
IN WASHINGTON, TREY.
HOUSE MINORITY LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY TWEETS OUT ACCORDING
TO PRESIDENT BIDEN AMERICANS CAN
EASILY GET TO THE AIRPORT IN
KABUL.
THEY CAN'T.
NO LONGER IN AFGHANISTAN
THEY'RE.
THE BORDER IS SECURE.
IT ISN'T.
REPUBLICANS, I MEAN, THEY HAVE
TO WANT THE SOLUTION BUT,
OBVIOUSLY, THEY ARE TAKING THIS
MOMENT TO SAY THIS IS SCREWED
UP.
>> I THINK PART OF WHAT KEVIN IS
DOING THERE IS JUST REMINDING
THE MEDIA HOW FASCINATED THEY
WERE WITH BIDEN'S EXPERIENCE AND
THIS WHOLE AMERICA IS BACK AND
THE REALITY IS, AMERICA IS
LEAVING AND TALIBAN IS BACK.
MY GUESS IS McCARTHY WAS
POKI